the bachelor in paradise investigation
is over after shutting down production
on the reality show's fourth season in
Mexico Warner Brothers has cleared the
cast of any misconduct releasing this
statement to ET Tuesday quote we do not
intend to release the videotape of the
incident we can say however that the
tape does not support any charge of
misconduct by a cast member nor does the
tape show contrary to many press reports
that the safety of any cast member was
ever in jeopardy the statement also
notes that production will resume with
new policies in place to ensure the
quote safety and security of everyone
involved in filming and an ABC
spokesperson tells ET the show will
still air this summer though a source
tells ET it's likely they'll resume
filming in a new location not in Mexico
the internal investigation was launched
after a sexual encounter between Demario
Jackson and Corrine elympios on the
first day of production led two
producers to file complaints of
misconduct reps for both Corinne and de
Mario told ET on Friday that neither of
their clients have seen footage of the
incident and neither party has filed a
complaint at this time but both have
hired lawyers a source close to Demario
tells ET that he is relieved the
investigation is over
quote he is just trying to clear his
name and move on this is a huge step
right here to clear his name
you